it's no surprise the game of thrones
produced some of the most talked about
moments of the past ten years on
television from baby dragons and sudden
beheadings to face swapping in The
Walking Dead here are some of the most
paused moments in Game of Thrones
history from the opening moments of Game
of Thrones first episode audiences are
immediately drawn to Ned Stark
the tragically noble patriarch of the
stark clan and his strong sense of honor
and duty along with his wife Catelyn
Ned is the proud parent of five children
Robb Sansa bran Arya and Rickon he's
also the father of Jon Snow
a bastard net produced while he was off
fighting a rebellion with King Robert
Baratheon or so he says throughout the
first season viewers follow Ned as he
leaves the stark family home of
Winterfell to serve his hand of the king
which starts him down the path that
leads inevitably to his death over the
course of the season
Ned discovers that Robert's eldest son
Joffrey isn't Robert's son at all he's
actually the product of a relationship
between Roberts Queen Cersei Lannister
and her twin brother Jaime when Ned
reveals the truth after Robert's death
he finds himself put on trial for high
treason he pleads guilty but it turns
out that Joffrey has a bit of a sadistic
streak to put it mildly this one's your
father this one here
look at it and see what happens to
traitors in one of his first acts as the
new King Joffrey has Ned beheaded in a
public execution in front of his family
with that the sword stroke her drown
Westeros simultaneously closed out the
first season of Game of Thrones and
taught viewers that nobody not even Ned
Stark was safe when audiences first meet
Daenerys Targaryen she's a far cry from
the Queen she will eventually become as
an exiled political pawn whose vicious
ruthless brother Viserys marries are off
to Khal Drogo to cement an alliance
Daenerys doesn't seem particularly
imposing however as she assimilates into
Khal Drogo's Dothraki tribe she finds
herself far more powerful than her
fallen family and it soon seems like the
eastern continents number one power
couple will soon conquer the world
unfortunately Drogo meets an untimely
end thanks to an infected wound and a
vindictive witch doctor leaving tenaris
on her own with a Dothraki horde luckily
she also has three dragon eggs and after
burning her late husband on a funeral
pyre she descends into the fire herself
along with the eggs by morning the fire
is gone and Daenerys is still alive
rising from the ashes with three newborn
dragons clinging to her naked body ready
to lead her to conquest by season three
Daenerys has given herself the
appropriate title of the mother of
dragons having successfully raised the
baby monsters into obedient adolescent
weapons of mass destruction but as
Daenerys makes her way towards Westeros
to claim her throne she discovers an
unknown horror on her side of the Narrow
Sea the slave trade to win his shield an
unsullied must go to the slave Mart's
with a silver mark find a newborn upon
visiting a stupor
Daenerys realizes she needs to assemble
an army if she's ever going to conquer
the armies of King's Landing so she
decides to make a trade with a
particularly cruel and repulsive slaver
Daenerys agrees to trade her largest
dragon drogon in exchange for his
powerful unsullied army and his
translator missandei but it turns out
that she has a few other terms and
conditions to this agreement once
Daenerys confirms that the Army is hers
she gives drogon a command
dracarys just like that the winged beast
torches both the slave trader and his
town giving us one of the best moments
in Game of Thrones with an army behind
her a trio of dragons and her first
victory under her belt
Daenerys truly becomes a conqueror in
one infinitely possible moment Game of
Thrones is well known by its fans for
being packed full of unbelievably brutal
moments but most of them pale in
comparison to the infamous red wedding
in the show's third season Robb Stark
walks back a deal with his mother's ally
Walder Frey in addition to being a gross
old man Walder Leeds House Frey and
controls an important river crossing
that could be the Starks key to holding
the north
unfortunately Robb follows his heart and
marries the woman he loves to Lisa
instead of one of Walter's many
daughters leaving Walder very angry
about their would-be alliance it seems
that the stark family calms the old man
down by offering up Kats brother for the
marriage instead and Walder accepts with
Robb Kat and a pregnant Talisa attending
the wedding party at the twins as
Walters guests don't get that warm
feeling about a happy ending just yet
though as the wedding band strikes up
the ominous tune the rains of castamere
Catelyn watches Walters men locking the
doors and it's obvious to everyone that
this wedding is about to go bad for the
good guys as ed mirror and his wife are
whisked to safety
Talisa and Rob are brutally dispatched
ending the short reign of the king of
the north in a matrimonial bloodbath the
final shot of the episode where Catelyn
mournfully eliminates one of Walter's
daughters only to have her own life
ended seconds later is one of Thrones
most disturbing and indelible images if
you ever get invited to a wedding in
Westeros it might be best just to send a
nice card and have something from the
registry delivered because they don't
tend to end well shortly after the red
wedding we get another nuptial disaster
to be fair though this one was
definitely a happy ending for viewers if
not for the blushing groom ever since
Ned's beheading his eldest daughter
Sansa remained captive at King's Landing
under the care of Joffrey and the
Lannisters
after King Robert dies as well Joffrey
takes the throne
luckily for Sansa Joffrey decides on a
new bride the beautiful and highborn
Margaery Tyrell he marries her in a
lavish ceremony making her the queen if
you've been paying attention it will not
surprise you to find out that while the
wedding is lovely the reception goes
awry and the most gruesome way possible
after emotionally torturing everyone at
the ceremony it seems like Joffrey
starts to choke on his cake but as it
turns out someone poisoned his wine and
he dies and his mother Circe's arms
while Sansa escapes as he takes his last
breath
Joffrey points to his befuddled uncle
Tyrion Lannister
setting up a season's worth of intrigue
with that fatal sip Joffrey's party
becomes known as the purple wedding and
puts an end to one of the show's most
brutal and despised characters while the
series is focused on the war for the
Iron Throne and control over the realm
there's another threat lurking in the
north slowly inching its way towards the
Seven Kingdoms despite a massive wall
that separates Westeros from the untamed
and mysterious wilds to the north the
terrifying White Walkers and their
undead army spend the entire show
heading toward Westeros on a mission to
eradicate all living things as the show
progresses the White Walkers show off
several frightening powers but the
scariest white Walker sequence of the
entire show takes place in the fifth
season as Jon Snow joins a group of
wildlings to try to convince them to
join the Nights Watch and fight against
the seemingly unstoppable walkers
they're attacked in one of the show's
most memorable combat sequences the good
guys put up a valiant fight but it's
clear from the start that they're
fighting a losing battle eventually snow
and his companions are overrun and
forced to retreat leaving hundreds of
wildlings to a horrible fate in complete
silence the leader of the White Walkers
the night king simply raises his arms
and revives all the people he just
slaughtered as vicious whites it's a
truly terrifying scene and it proves
just how frightening the walkers really
are
unfortunately for Jon Snow his alliance
with the wildlings doesn't go over well
with the other members of the Nights
Watch when he returns to their
headquarters at Castle black
despite the fact that he's simply trying
to save humanity by assembling as large
of an army as possible his fellow
Knights watchmen feel powerless and
betrayed by Jon's
on an alliance with their longtime
enemies one night his mutinous men
finally devised a plan after luring him
outside John's men turn on him and take
turns stabbing him to death Julius
Caesar style leaving him for dead as the
fifth season draws to a close for the
watch obviously this was one of the
biggest cliffhangers in modern
television history especially with the
show's history of killing off the guy
you thought was the main character
shortly ended the show's sixth season
though John made his way back to the
realm of the living with a little help
from Westeros 'as resident red priestess
Melisandre Jon Snow's death was an
incredible moment in his own right
but his return couldn't have been more
satisfying Game of Thrones add no
shortage of incredible battle sequences
during its eighth season run but the
best of the best by far
is definitely season sixes battle of the
bastards it's the epic and long-awaited
showdown between Jon Snow and Ramsay
Bolton the vicious cruel legitimized
bastard of Roose Bolton before the show
even begins Ramsay racks up a long list
of insults and offenses towards the
Starks including brutalizing Jon's
sister Sansa taking control of
Winterfell and executing Rick and Stark
right as the battle begins
so yeah this one isn't about the Iron
Throne it's personal the entire battle
is made up of moments that deserve to be
paused from Jon's heroic charge onto the
battlefield to the moment where he's
nearly trampled by horses and buried by
fallen soldiers but the show's final
stretch delivers victory after victory
between the moment where Jon beats
Ramsay to a pulp to the climax where
Sansa feeds her tormentor to his own
hungry hounds the Battle of the bastards
will keep you pausing and rewinding from
start to finish by the final episode of
season six Cersei Lannister has faced
enough humiliation to last a lifetime
with her last living child Tommen and
his bride Margaery on the throne the
Queen Mother has been accurately accused
of adultery incest and other high crimes
by the ultra-religious high Sparrow
whose cult is all but overtaken King's
Landing after forcing Cersei to walk
naked through the city and face abuse
from her
subjects the high Sparrow wants her to
stand trial at the Sept of Baelor for a
little more public shaming Cersei
however has a very different spectacle
in mind while Margery the high Sparrow
and most of King's Landing wait for
Cersei in the Sept viewers see her
coolly watching things from a high tower
biding her time until the entire Sept
explodes thanks to a blast of wildfire
it's a sequence with several beautifully
framed shots worthy of pausing and an
undeniable victory for Cersei even
though it leads poor Tommen to leap to
his death out of grief it's the perfect
way to close out a season with a bang as
Game of Thrones drew to a close
everything seemed to lead to two points
who would take the Iron Throne and
whether or not the night king could even
be defeated at all ultimately nobody got
the throne but the night king met his
end thanks to an unexpected attack as
the White Walkers descend upon
Winterfell and our favorite remaining
characters or what's left of them all
hope seems lost especially because the
night king can conjure a new army out of
dead bodies any time he wants as the
humans try to hold off the army of
undead and White Walkers the night king
is getting closer and closer to his
target bran Stark the situation looks
dire until fully trained assassin Arya
Stark leaps from the darkness and kills
the night king herself a highlight of
the final season Arya Starks biggest
kill is a stunning twist providing Game
of Thrones with one of its all-time best
moments check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell C don't miss a
single one
[Music]